Jaisalmer,
la cité d'or se dresse
au-dessus du désert,
perdu à l'extrême ouest de l'Inde.
La forteresse n'a pas bougé
depuis le Moyen-âge
et les mentalités aussi.
Les hommes depuis des millénaires
s'accrochent à une tradition barbare,
ils tuent leurs filles.
Sarotje a onze ans et c'est une rescapée.
Sa mère s'est battue pour la garder.
et son père, heureusement, a suivi.
Mais il y a eu un prix à payer pour
ne pas avoir respecté la tradition.
La famille a dû quitter son village.
- Je n'aimais pas vivre au village.
Il n'y a pas de filles là-bas.
En fait, il n'y avait qu'une fille.
Du coup, moi, j'avais qu'une amie.
Le reste, ce ne sont que des garçons.
Pour cette société, Sarotje,
comme beaucoup de filles, est un fardeau.
Au Rajastan, les filles, ça ne travaille pas,
ça ne rapporte pas d'argent.
Elles ne transmettent pas non plus
le nom de la famille.
Et puis surtout, un jour,
il faut les marier.
Et ça coûte beaucoup d'argent.
Jangpa a donné quatre fois la vie.
À Sarotje, à son petit frère Rajiv,
mais aussi à deux autres filles
qu'elle n'a pas eu la force de sauver.
- Quand tu as eu ta première fille,
tu as dû la tuer toi même ?
- Je l'ai étouffé avec du sable.
- Tu as fait ça ?
- C'est ma belle-mère qui m'a demandé ça.
- Elle t'a dit de le faire ?
Mais tu as essayé de refuser,
de lui dire non ?
- Non...
- Tu as juste fait ce qu'elle te disait ?
- Je n'ai pas refusé
parce que c'est la tradition.
On n'a pas le choix, il faut écouter.
Personne ne peut refuser.
J'étais une toute jeune fille.
Qu'est-ce que je pouvais faire ?
Tout le monde disait : "Elle a donné naissance
à une fille, on va la t***."
C'est notre tradition.
Ils m'ont dit de le faire et je l'ai fait.
Quand ma seconde fille est née,
ma belle-sœur et ma belle-mère
l'ont prise.
Moi, je me suis caché le visage.
Je ne voulais pas voir ça.
Elles l'ont mise dans une boîte.
Elle était nue, elle n'avait pas d'habits.
C'était tout de suite après sa naissance.
C'est ce qu'on fait ici.
On les met dans une boîte,
puis on les recouvre de terre.
Ensuite, on les laisse comme ça
toute la nuit, on les étouffe lentement.
Le lendemain, avant le lever du soleil,
ils sont venus,
ils ont emporté la boîte
et sont partis l'enterrer quelque part.
Puis ils sont rentrés.
Ils ont lavé leurs mains, leurs pieds
et ils ont pris le premier repas
de la journée.
- Elle te manque, ta fille ?
Continuer à vivre,
mais à quel prix ?
Il y a les fantômes qui hantent
l'esprit de Jangpa.
Et puis la culpabilité qui ronge
celui de Sarotje.
Celle d'être là.
Alors que ses sœurs
n'ont plus aucune chance.
Et puis il y a la vie qui
sans cesse rappelle ce souvenir,
chaque retour au village
qui est douloureux.
À mesure que défile le bitume,
on rejoint le cœur de la tragédie,
le lieu où cette tradition
des infanticides prend racine.
Ce village, c'est l'un de ceux qui compte
aujourd'hui le plus grand déséquilibre
entre hommes et femmes
de tout le continent indien.
On est au bout du monde.
Et après l'école,
il n'y a que des garçons,
pour jouer dans ces rues poussiéreuses.
Sarotje est de retour.
Et aujourd'hui, sa mère l'emmène
chez la femme qui lui a sauvé la vie.
C'était il y a onze ans.
- Soyez les bienvenues.
Allez, on y va !
Gajendra est une figure connue
dans tout le Rajasthan.
C'est la première femme, il y a 30 ans,
à avoir défié l'ordre établi,
à s'être opposée à l'infanticide.
Cette femme d'un milieu aisé est devenue
le modèle de milliers de villageoises.
Comme Jangpa.
- Gajendra a toujours dit
qu'il fallait sauver les filles.
Elle insiste : les filles doivent vivre !
Mais les femmes du village
n'écoutent pas ces paroles.
Elle m'a expliqué que garder
ma fille était juste.
Ce sont des choses
que je ne comprenais pas avant,
mais dont je suis consciente aujourd'hui.
C'est parce que j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps avec elle.
- Quand ma première fille est née,
ma famille n'était pas contente du tout.
Ma belle-mère en particulier.
Ils se réjouissaient tous
à l'idée d'avoir un garçon.
Personne, bien sûr, ne m'a dit en face
qu'ils ne voulaient pas garder ma fille,
mais c'est parce que mon mari était à mes côtés
qu'elle est vivante aujourd'hui.
Il m'a soutenu de toute
son autorité et leur a dit :
"Personne ne fera de problèmes à ma femme.
Les enfants qui naîtront ici
dans cette maison,
quel que soit leur sexe, ils vivront."
C'est là que mon combat a commencé.
À partir de ce moment, des femmes du village
sont venues me chercher régulièrement.
Elles me disaient : "Ma belle famille ne veut pas
garder ma fille, il faut que tu leur parles !"
Avec Gajendra, une toute petite révolution
est en marche dans ces villages.
Sarotje, en tout cas,
lui sera reconnaissante à jamais.
Mais pour sa vie sauvée,
combien d'autres encore continueront
à être sacrifiées ?
C'est le chant des morts qui plane
aujourd'hui au-dessus du village.
Chaque mois, on leur rend hommage.
Chaque mois aussi, c'est ce jour
que choisissent les hommes pour se réunir.
Les Panchayats,
ce sont des tribunaux populaires,
des organisations officiellement interdites,
mais qui régissent encore la vie de centaines
de millions d'Indiens dans les campagnes.
Ici, on s'accroche au pouvoir
tout autant qu'aux traditions.
- Mon nom est Malabuchan.
Je suis un guerrier Rajput.
J'ai six enfants, tous des garçons.
Ils sont mariés et chacun d'entre eux
a eu deux fils.
Que des garçons
mais c'est juste de la chance !
Nous, les rajputs,
les guerriers du Rajasthan,
on est très attachés
à la domination des hommes.
Si une fille fait des études,
elle n'écoutera plus son père et sa mère.
Elle voudra alors voir du monde,
sortir de la maison.
Comment on peut laisser
sortir une fille ?
Si quelqu'un la voit traîner dehors,
les gens viendront me voir.
"On a vu ta fille traîner avec des garçons".
On sera alors montrés
du doigt et plus grave,
cette fille-là,
on ne pourra plus jamais la marier.
- On a peur de ça.
Si elles deviennent l'égal des hommes,
elles ne voudront plus travailler à la maison,
donc on ne veut pas qu'elles soient éduquées.
Elles pourraient rompre avec notre culture.
J'ai déjà vu ça bien des fois
et j'en ai tiré mes conclusions.
Si on ne garde pas nos filles,
c'est parce qu'elles coûtent beaucoup d'argent.
Surtout au moment du mariage.
Il faut l'équivalent de 15 000€
au moins pour une fille.
Alors imaginez si on en avait trois.
Les belles familles réclament 8 000€
pour les fiançailles,
puis 15 000€ le jour du mariage
pour accepter notre fille dans leur famille.
Les gens parlent toujours
des filles qu'on tue,
mais ils ne connaissent pas
tous nos problèmes.
Sur ces terres, les hommes tiennent
les mêmes discours depuis des siècles.
Les traditions et les coutumes
sont profondément ancrées.
Personne ici ne veut parler
directement des infanticides.
Mais ces hommes ont été élevés
ainsi par leurs pères
et ces valeurs,
ils les transmettront à leurs fils.
Pas facile pour Gajendra
de faire face à ce conservatisme.
En 30 années, elle a bien
sauvé quelques fillettes,
mais elle sait que ce drame se poursuit
dans beaucoup de maisons,
à l'abri des regards.
- Vous voyez cette maison, juste en face ?
Dans cette maison, ils ont tué
au moins 6 ou 7 petites filles.
Officiellement, aucune de leurs belles filles
n'a donné naissance à une fille.
Il n'y a que des garçons
qui naissent chez eux.
Venez, on s'en va.
Regardez cette maison.
Une fille est née, mais la mère
ne voulait pas s'en occuper.
Je lui ai dit : "Tu vas aller en prison
si tu te débarrasses de ta fille."
Alors, elle s'est calmée un certain temps.
Elle est sortie de l'hôpital et rentrée
au village, je suis retournée la voir.
Puis je suis rentrée me coucher.
Le lendemain matin, j'ai appris
que sa famille avait tué le bébé.
Mon cœur s'est rempli d'amertume.
Le cœur de Jangpa, lui,
est rempli de crainte.
Avec sa fille, ce soir,
elles ne rentreront pas à la maison.
Jangpa nous a parlé sans l'autorisation
de son mari et il est fou de rage.
Elle va passer la nuit chez une amie,
en espérant que demain
la colère sera retombée.
- J'ai peur de mon mari.
Ce n'est pas dans notre culture,
dans nos traditions de parler comme ça.
Mon mari va hurler.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'il va me faire
s'il me retrouve ce soir, il va boire
et puis il va se mettre à ma recherche.
Après, il va peut-être même me battre,
je ne sais pas.
- C'est notre vie. On ne pourra
jamais quitter nos maris.
Si on les quittait, ce serait un crime.
On nous ferait passer pour des folles.
Toute notre vie, on n'aura pas
d'autre choix.
Peu importe ce qu'ils font, peu importe
qu'ils aient raison ou tort,
on est condamné à les suivre.
Les hommes ne veulent pas
que les choses changent.
Ils veulent conserver
leur position, leur autorité.
Ils veulent continuer à décider
de chaque chose.
Mais un jour peut-être, ils se mettront
à prendre en considération nos idées.
Ce jour-là, ça voudra dire qu'on est libre !
Alors, on s'arrêtera
de s'occuper de leur maison.
On ne fera plus rien et enfin, ils auront
perdu leur autorité et tous leurs droits.
Je ne vais pas avoir de problèmes ?
Vous êtes sûre ? Sinon mon mari me tuerait !